what a room full of talented and  inspirational people and what the hell  am I doing here in the midst of you  David O Russell thank you so much mate  for making the work that all of us  actors did actually mean something the  the just incredible work of every actor  Melissa Amy Jack Mark Dickie and Mickey  where's my quacker is he out there think  he's out there somewhere wait hey mate  you're the best he's had a wonderful  story  and I can't wait to see the next chapter  if you want to be a champ if you want to  go train with him go meet with him dick  eckland.com go do it check him out okay  all right he deserves it and uh of  course mostly my wonderful wife  I didn't think I was like this I thought  my wonderful wife who's my uh Mast  through the storms of life I hope I'm  likewise to you darling and my our  little girl  who's taught me so much more than I'll  ever be able to teach her thank you  thank you so much